Oh Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith hi
I'm mark oh my god I should have savored
that a little more is the last time
we'll ever say it no we do one more take
- I can do this I'm a director I do this
[ __ ] all the time
we'll just do another take welcome to
fat man on Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I am mark Barnard very very bittersweet
but all good things come to an end mark
as we all know and I'm shocked we made
it as far as we did without Warner
Brothers being like [ __ ] you I mean it
was really a feature in the Justice
League period - well you really didn't
so if anything I was like they're gonna
come for him first but uh they were very
cool then never see us even now there's
never like I just hosted a thing for
them last week the launch of DC Universe
they had a live stream and stuff it was
wonderful and nobody came over to be
like you know you don't own that
character right like you know so I it
was nice of them but sooner or later the
axe would fall and then couple that with
the fact that like a lot of people were
like you've lost too much weight it's
false advertising so I felt like it was
time to change and we talked about last
week that the the largest suggestion
from the internet from multiple parties
was fat man beyond which like we both
fell in love with
I threw it off to Jeff Quigley this week
our our master artist he came up with a
really cool show artwork piece of
artwork and stuff so we felt like I
what's the point we're gonna wait well
yeah we're thinking like maybe we'll
wait till January and [ __ ] but we're
like why like what episode is the last
one was 3:19 or - 29 - 29 so
that makes this one 230 yes all right so
the last fat man I'm Batman will be 230
and then from 231 on it'll be fat man
beyond the next live show we're going to
do on Batman day which is September 15th
it's a Saturday which we rarely do the
show on a Saturday so mark your
calendars man that will be the official
launch of fat man beyond which as a
title I think works on a couple
different levels not only is a nod to of
course the Batman universe and stuff
which spawned the show but you know it
it is kind of like fat man be on not
just like hey he's beyond a fat man now
or something like that but but it
started as one thing and it's gone
beyond that it's become something
different and stuff thoughts are we
gonna remember because it's so [ __ ]
comic book to do that I know but it's
it's what a pain in the ass that is you
know Moses and people were like are you
gonna keep it on the same stream do we
have to rejoin and stuff no we'll just
change the name within the stream I mean
I don't know like it's not like you know
oh I've got episode 1 in a polybag with
[ __ ] a cardboard but you know you
can't collect it or something like that
so you say that some [ __ ] show
up or like an acetate pressings fat man
be on number one no doubt I don't know I
think well maybe we keep it the same
here's the here's the upshot though like
in two years we can go back to the
original numbering and then it's a big
[ __ ] deal oh man they got you people
ruined you man next you'll he's trying
to sell me on chromium covers man no way
can you show us on the doll where they
hurt you it is it's weird to see it kind
of well I mean it doesn't come to an end
we just evolved into something else and
stuff and there were you know it
certainly gets rid of any impending
legal action by dropping the Batman from
the title and stuff but somebody pointed
out on Twitter like aside from that this
doesn't solve your problem at all this
there's still fat man in the title but
I'm like no it's fat man
in the second word yeah yeah there's two
words in the equation so next time we do
it'll be that but for now let's enjoy
the last times bittersweet it is and of
course we will [ __ ] up our intro like 98
times going forward yeah no doubt
welcome to fat man yeah this is like
going on like a final date with your
boyfriend or girlfriend before you go
off to college and or and your how many
[ __ ] people around this day a lot of
us boyfriend and my girlfriend and we're
all going off for dinner I got I figured
for like the modern youth okay
they probably um they're omnivorous when
it comes to [ __ ] so they probably
have both girlfriends their boyfriends I
was covering all the bases it's beyond
for me man yeah I it's I don't know it
just it feels like the right time
all right but it but it is kind of weird
to see the end of one ERA and stuff I
know I also reserve the right to we
could stuff we ever like people always
bitching like do [ __ ] interviews like
you used to do and stuff like that
those are fun but that I honestly enjoy
this coordination incarnation of the
show much more and stuff but if they're
ever down the line you know sit downs
with people and stuff we'll put those
specifically now the title gets to go
back to the interview format so if we're
ever sit down at in my house in the
formerly fat cave with with guests
who've worked on Batman that fall into
the traditional definition of what the
show used to be then those episodes will
be called fat man I'm Batman
but this fat man be honest so now it's
like an imprint now like use it gonna
deal when we do the throwback episodes
those will be the old thing this is a
new thing like it's absolutely a
lenticular cover version of what they
used to be a little bit and wait till we
get to our third incarnation when we're
in our 80s fat man forever
Geron should we do the dark knight
coming to retract now did you say the
grim knight as in the Grim Reaper I'm
your black racer black racer excellent
alright so yeah it'll it's there's many
more incarnations to come and stuff but
this incarnation will still function the
same way they've all function we'll
chitchat a little bit before we dive it
in the news which you've been working on
uh I was on vacation over Labor Day
weekend what was that like
it was kind of boss it really was it was
it was a little I went to San Francisco
for the weekend and tried my best to
have the nerdiest time that I possibly
could while I was there so I went to
Alcatraz as one does right and and
almost every place I went I just kept on
going welcome to the rock I [ __ ] the
prom queen Oh Matt you piece of [ __ ] and
like those poor [ __ ] who work at
Alcatraz must be subjected to millions
of Sean Connery impressions whenever
anyone goes to visit everyone's like wow
come to the rock no like [ __ ] again man
I got the most like pained polite smiles
like oh you think you're the first oh
well yes welcome to the rock I'm sure
you saw a movie once I get it you have
to you have to probably come with a line
that people like what's that and you're
like the rock and they're like oh [ __ ]
that's from the rock and then you start
a conversation or something like that
that's awesome one of the entomology of
your name Goodspeed
and we're to go back to the first line I
don't know if they on the rock [ __ ]
cut totally for all I knew that was from
[ __ ] Humphrey
for the Lord for a good trip might I
suggest st. Lawrence Cathedral in Topeka
Kansas is that from the movie totally
it's just like last [ __ ] lines as he
sends into there's a pruder film I think
do you want to see who killed Kennedy oh
that's right you remember a lot about
that [ __ ] movie I am and you know who
was not impressed every guard [ __ ]
they could give a [ __ ] that I saw a
movie eighteen times before I showed up
on the rock I watched I rewatched
sneakers last night because we I think
either we mentioned it or maybe I
mentioned it Mosier on podcast or Brian
jaws I forget but somewhere sneakers
have popped up and I remember that day I
was like [ __ ] I'm gonna rewatch that
[ __ ] and then I rewatched it last night
and I had a [ __ ] good time although I
will admit halfway through it it's like
is this how you want to spend your
[ __ ] life like you almost died do you
just want to rewatch movies you've seen
a hundred times and the answer was yes
so I'm obviously on the right path so
but now when you like we just spent
enough time on the rock where I'm
sitting here gone like I know what I'm
watching when I get home tonight I'm
gonna check all those lines and see how
closely good yeah I went to I went to
Chinatown for dinner I mean I ate like
tomorrow was a rumor when I was in San
Francisco cuz that's what you [ __ ] do
but you start with the Chinatown and had
a whole lot of a China is here mr.
Burton the [ __ ] do you mean China is
here do they not get the reference none
of them did because you know it turns
out they're like a black dude making big
trouble little China references in
Chinatown I was like really like this is
like two steps to racist for us you
should get back on your bus egg
then what happened then I went to muir
woods where they shot all the indoor
[ __ ] in Marin County the giant redwood
forest that is just over the gold you
can do that you just go over here super
free really yeah
both indoor and is there an entrance or
is it just like we're here look yeah
like there's this huge [ __ ] mountain
road you got to climb up and over and
down you got a call ahead to get parking
reservations because it's so this was
the thing
it's a [ __ ] thing and there's a
beautiful trail that leads you through
and they don't point out like here is
where [ __ ] wicked got shot I wish they
would but they didn't but you can still
[ __ ] you're on Endor for all intents
and purposes you are on Endor and also
where the monkeys
ran to in Rison plan of the aides same
woods the same woods to go over the
Golden Gate Bridge which also super cool
and then they spring their way into the
woods and then Cesar you know ape no
kill ape didn't in the ex with the third
x-men movie that what's-his-name
directed they were hiding in those woods
cuz then he [ __ ] with the bridge
magneto and [ __ ]
those woods of featured prominently in
all really Oh what else did you do in
San Francisco that sounds like a packed
plate it really was I took a
super-expensive trolley ride cable car
ride cuz it's it's like seven bucks a
person so I went with my family so there
was like 28 bucks to get on the [ __ ]
trolley and take it to like five blocks
again to stop another 20 bucks to get
back on the [ __ ] trolley to take it
back to walk up this [ __ ] hell if you
see in these hills [ __ ] so we're
gonna do burr to go back to the car like
feels weird there's a cable car right
there guys I eat a bread bowl full of
clam chowder cuz you have to do that is
that part of the experience even before
my like like diet change I just not a
seafood guy grew up in a seafood town so
I've never eaten seafood in my entire
life
just [ __ ] smells like home
and I escaped at a young age yeah and I
liked the home buzz never I've you know
my father ate fish all the time so I saw
it and the consistency really [ __ ]
with me because I'm like it looks like
jello but it's a meat [ __ ] this and then
we drove home like we flew up and then
we rented a car and drove back home so
we could drive how long is that coast to
do it the way we did it which is to see
all of the [ __ ] [ __ ] along the coast
it's about 10 hours there's a beeline on
the 101 you could do it in six but then
all you see is the 101 and what's the
point that's true I've done that one and
I did not get fired on my drive back
home which the last time I was in San
Francisco with my wife I got fired on my
way back to LA who fired you
Entertainment Weekly did seriously yeah
nine nine years ago I went for my 10th
anniversary trip and it was awesome
because I was still working at he W and
I called like a couple of publicist
friends I'm like hey
Lucasfilm you know would be awesome if I
could come to your ranch and see [ __ ]
and then we're like of course you can
come on we'll give you a tour and we'll
go to the Presidio and do the ILM thing
and then we'll drive by the Black Rock e
to get wave at animators who don't see
the light of day and we can show you all
the cool [ __ ] and it was amazing and I
got to touch the fertility Idol which I
talked about before that I would buy if
I could write they don't ever sell I've
got pregnant so it's fancy that after
you touch the fertility god it was
phenomenal and I was driving back to LA
to continue like the last button in my
vacation and I got a call while I'm like
the [ __ ] just passed Big Sur I pull
over it's like hey so I know you're on
vacation but we just want to let you
know we're laying you off and I said why
did you have to call me today I don't
wait until I got home you lay me off
when I show back at work on Monday but
like [ __ ] you but no they called me on
my vacation I said well it's we're
laying off a bunch of people and we have
to contract we notify everybody at the
same time so it's not showing some kind
of preference versus one person over
another so sorry enjoy the rest of your
vacation
[Music]
I'll try yeah I'm like what the force
was with me like five minutes ago I took
the fertility fertility [ __ ] you
touch an agility guide could tip here as
to the Temple of Doom really didn't got
the movie wires crossed man oh he was
your Last Crusade [ __ ] I got um
num shevai right out of a job
I am I it was just my I've you know we
had a TV show up till about a minute ago
called comic book men an AMC let me know
that it was canceled on the day of my
anniversary I was in New York with my
wife at shed and I got a text from
somebody it was just like you around and
I wanted to text back yeah but not for
bad news its my anniversary instead I
just like wrote yeah and then they said
you want to call and I said oh man this
ain't never good and I was like okay and
the call was yeah hey you know [ __ ]
we love you guys but not enough and so
you know and but for me it wasn't like
oh this ruins everything
we you know seven seasons 96 episodes I
had nothing to [ __ ] about and I
expected that call at the end of season
one so the fact that you know we gone
six more seasons before they made that
call was everything but it was weird you
know I told my wife she's like they had
to tell you today and I was like don't
worry I'm still gonna [ __ ] that's up to
you it's all I have left
yeah really I got a job to worry about
so I got plenty of time to [ __ ] I
remember before I left on that vacation
my the number two I was working for the
website at the time it's okay what's
your cell phone number for the files and
now [ __ ] calls to lend me off
I'm like you mother for now I know why
you needed my cell phone number
lose that [ __ ] I don't any more calls
from you
they're like no problem now click yeah
and now anytime I go on vacation I'm
like you don't get to have my number I'm
going off the grid any bad news can wait
for me when I get home
[ __ ] you job goodbye very very smart
tread stones like we'll leave them alone
till he gets home yeah why doesn't my
pass work I can't get on the lot hence I
can't spy on Game of Thrones how's that
going the spying on Game of Thrones not
well moving on no I'm gonna try it like
every times ok guys very funny if
somewhere they're doing a podcast sort
of like we're trying to spy on tread
stones
oh yeah who's bring brownies we'll let
you in these [ __ ] have cameras
and retinal scans and thumb prints and
your eyes tracking that gets you don't
believe what they want to touch it's
like Marvin my marvel level security
very much which I believe has a lot of
coffee involved in it
using a whole fist duck speaking of
[ __ ] marvel security man it's getting
lakhs cuz brie Larson just tweeted
before a couple hours ago before the
show began hey II W want to break the
internet tomorrow they said very very
subtle and very you know I have I
thought immediately I was like oh my god
they're gonna debut a trailer for sequel
to the to room but uh but then I
realized when II W tweeted her back like
that would be marvelous I started
thinking to myself this could have
something to do with Captain Marvel and
I was just thinking the other day it's
been a minute you know other than the
release of infinity war on home video
there's been a minute since we've been
hyped for the next movie it's been quiet
on the Marvel front yeah was that about
I I mean it's I think some of it is
because the world is going so fast that
I realized the other day
thanks to my shirt that Black Panther
was out this year like it feels like
that Panther was
forty-eight years ago yeah some February
yeah remember that time we were all
excited about that movie and then it
came and we were super [ __ ] thrilled
and now that seems like that was a like
Mesozoic era of you in kitchen we've got
a lot more choices now but like the
shelf life is way shorter than it ever
was before it's like the shelf life of
[ __ ] milk I'm oh [ __ ] where it's like
you didn't see that [ __ ] spoiled move
on man
yeah you're right I'm not about that
Black Panther feels kind of not old but
like oh that happened last year but it's
easy to forget that like ant-man and the
wasp ever came out yeah oh that's right
we got that in [ __ ] August right and
it was fun - it wasn't like oh it's
forgettable it was like a good time and
be like four hundred million dollars
like it did well but it just poof I
finally saw two movies this week I
caught up with a movie in the theater
and I was kind of pissed off because not
pissed off but like my wife was I was
trying to [ __ ] see Jurassic world the
fallen Kingdom since it came out I don't
like I don't make apologies I like a
good dinosaur movie so and and I trust
that brand that's like the coca-cola of
dinosaur movies like you know exactly
what you're gonna get tried and true
tested formula they tried new coke once
that was Jurassic Park 3 they went back
to the classic [ __ ] formula and [ __ ]
like that so I you know I was looking
forward to I couldn't get anybody to go
with me and [ __ ] my wife's like I'm
gonna see that so finally you know as
Labor Day weekend I'm like god damn it
on the labourer like I want to [ __ ] I
want to celebrate now I want to
celebrate is I want to go see Jurassic
world and she was like you could have
asked for anything you asked for that
and I was like this all I want so she
went with me to go see it and while we
were driving she's just like I don't
even know why we're doing this it's
gonna be on home video like any minute I
was like [ __ ] it's on home video
today
[Laughter]
couldn't watch this ship from the
comfort of my bed on a giant TV but you
know what I'm a director so going to see
a movie in a movie theater you know
[ __ ] every once in a while it's still
got to do it so how far did you have to
go to find that in the [ __ ] theater
in Pacoima
I mean well which I don't even know
where that is it sounds far it sounds
like John McClane would confuse it for
another closer town I don't I had to go
I did I went very close I lived very
close to the to the Grauman's Chinese
Theatre and so they had like one show
per day at it there and I was like that
must be because it's huge and you know
admittedly the movie came out what a May
or some [ __ ] so I'm a little behind
I enjoyed it though but [ __ ] is there
anything have I seen anything sadder in
a movie theater this year than the lone
dinosaur on the dock who's like what the
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like oh my god and they milked this [ __ ]
out of it everyone on the boat is like
my turn the [ __ ] around oh my god that
was [ __ ] heartbreaking man looked
over at my wife and she was like [ __ ]
my gosh it was well done and then I
finally did see something sadder in a
movie theater I went to see Christopher
Robin holy [ __ ] what emotional larceny
this [ __ ] is man oh my god you get in
and before the movie begins they hit you
with that [ __ ] Dumbo trailer where
the like cry [ __ ] you know and my kid is
like I begged my kid to go with me she's
like that movie's gonna make me cry was
like that's why we're doing it man we're
gonna say my mom totally we're gonna
mainline emotion and [ __ ] like that
it's a privilege of a movie let's you
[ __ ] cry and [ __ ] let's go do it so I
sold her on that angle and she loves
[ __ ] Disney but she'd been avoiding
that movie because she doesn't want to
[ __ ] cry my wife won't go at all
she's like I don't need to [ __ ] pay
like twice for a movie like you pay your
ticket and my ticket to watch you
[ __ ] cry the whole way through I'll
watch you do it when it's
on home video for free and [ __ ] so I
convinced my kid to go with and she
bought her boy brought her boyfriend
with her and so we're watching the flick
they hit that Dumbo trailer the kid has
avoided it at all cost because she knows
it'll kill her she's loved elephants our
whole [ __ ] life and [ __ ] like that
she's never even seen the Dumbo cartoon
she doesn't even know the movie but she
knows the beats and she knows it will
[ __ ] destroy her emotionally the kids
soft mark very soul so they're playing
the Dumbo trailer and yeah I'm sitting
in this chair she's next to me Corey's
next to her and the trailer begins with
like baby mine like a really haunting
[ __ ] rendition of baby mine all I
hear from the left is oh she's literally
turned away from the movie refusing to
watch in [ __ ] I'm like it's the trailer
and then I [ __ ] she kept looking away
she wouldn't look and [ __ ] and finally
like I've seen the trailer online so I
knew when they were gonna show that
[ __ ] and like it's the biggest
cute bomb you've ever seen in your life
like the digital Dumbo looks adorable
amazing those eyes and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so I
was like I know if she sees this
elephant she's gonna whale man so as it
was coming up and they put him up on the
[ __ ] podium right before he [ __ ]
flies and [ __ ] like that spoilers and
and I was like look oh my God look and
she looks up at the screen right at the
perfect moment she's a guy so she was
destroyed before [ __ ] you know
Christopher Robin even began and [ __ ]
and in the beginning of Christopher
Robin you saw it or no no in the
beginning of it they it's it's it's
really wonderful but in the beginning of
it they do the like kind of in
comic-book speak they do the last story
like the story and it didn't happen in
any of the real poo books but the story
of Christopher Robin when he says
goodbye to everyone in the Hundred Acre
Woods because he's go or wood because
he's going off to boarding school you
know and they're all like boring school
and
Bava and [ __ ] like that and so they
they're do the smartest [ __ ] in the
world they open the movie with talking
Pooh and Piglet like they established
that [ __ ] from the first scene they
don't make you wait for it because
that's what I was paying for I was like
show me these [ __ ] talking animals
like oh god they look adorable they look
plush I'll buy everyone if you show me
um right now and I thought I'd have to
wait 20 minutes in but [ __ ] they just
like it's like opening Disney title and
[ __ ] and then plow man they show him
hanging out with everybody having a
party it's going away party everything's
miss pelvin [ __ ] cuz they think animals
are stupid and so and you know he's like
saying goodbye and [ __ ] like that and
then they take the artwork now if I a
mil knee he wrote the stories right
he didn't draw those little renderings
that was somebody else I think the other
person that's credited whenever I think
Winnie the Pooh and those drawings that
aren't the Disney drawings I think of
the name a a Milne but that's the writer
so I should really learn the [ __ ]
dude who drew the original Pooh the in
the opening credits they use that
artwork from the house at Pooh Corner
and all those books and stuff and show
the growth of Christopher Robin so
they're like chapter one in which
Christopher Robin says goodbye to his
friends chapter two in which Christopher
Robin begins an adventure of boarding
school Chapter three in which
Christopher Robin receives terrible news
finds out his father dies and stuff so
they chart his life and then while it's
going on periodically they cut back to
the Hundred Acre Wood and Pooh is
looking at the door that Christopher
Robin used to come through waiting for
him holy [ __ ] dude first one of those
shots I was like oh no
and they show the door getting covered
and old and [ __ ] like Christopher Robin
ain't coming back and they love this
[ __ ] all the animals in the Hunter rig
oh he's like they're Jesus so he's a big
figure in all their lives and him not
being there is a big [ __ ] problem and
[ __ ] so but in a real world this is
something they did that I was [ __ ]
fascinated by to tell the story of adult
Christopher Robin like how could you
forget these talkin [ __ ] animals like
who forgets Winnie the Pooh who forgets
piglet who the [ __ ] grows up and [ __ ]
like you know my god I used to hang out
with a [ __ ] owl who spoke to me like
you would never leave that [ __ ] behind
but they come up with a plausible reason
why he left it all behind they show him
as a soldier in World War two like
[ __ ] gunfire going off and he's like
we need help like they don't show him
killing anybody I was sitting there
going if they show Christopher Robin
going taking a life like no wonder he's
like [ __ ] Pooh like but they show them
in battle bad enough like [ __ ] like
calling for help and [ __ ] gunfire going
off all around it's [ __ ] harrowing
and [ __ ] you let me come like an opium
addict and that one no he doesn't come
back like I'm [ __ ] haunted but he
comes back a grown up like how do you
[ __ ] talk about you know oh my bear
he loved honey you know when [ __ ]
it's like I've seen my brothers killed
and worn [ __ ] this is the first three
minutes of the movie dude this is all
the opening credits like they don't even
get into the meat of the movie they set
it up all perfectly in the opening
credits about how a boy becomes a man
and leaves behind like you know [ __ ]
the world of fantasy and [ __ ] and then
it becomes hook you know it's like Robin
Williams like grew up and became like
the not a great dad and his [ __ ] kid
it's like hey man don't you want to play
and he's like study your books and
Christopher Robin of all people wound up
working at a like a luggage company like
that's like all about imagination and
he's like we sell luggage so it was a
weird it's not the way I personally
would have done it I think with that
recipe you could have like squeezed
everyone's heart for every last [ __ ]
job was left but I cried a [ __ ] ton
because he's got emotional
baggage keV what do you mean that's why
he sells luggage number one number one
you never filed that that just made it
[ __ ] work why would I wish I'd gone
to see it with you instead of my weeping
ass kid man who is it no [ __ ] help
whatsoever man somebody might have
explained that that's [ __ ] good do
you think that was the intention that's
my guess
otherwise why luggage could have been
pots and pans you know what I'm saying
I mean they used it in the end like in
the third actor like this is how luggage
ties in but I like the way you did it
[ __ ] more now I want to know if that
was the case well that's called Disney
[Music]
it was it's a pretty good it's pretty
good watch very [ __ ] emotional man I
was crying like a [ __ ] bastard but at
the end of it you know like I was like
hey man I get it like [ __ ] that's why
I give Disney my money that I like their
drug like it makes I know exactly what
I'm gonna get makes me feel a very
specific way and [ __ ] takes me to a
wonderful [ __ ] place and [ __ ] so like
that's why I'm in on it like I and I'm
in on it I know to hustle like I'm not
stupid like [ __ ] this ain't real that
barring real and [ __ ] like that but I
buy into it like this is I like it go
ahead right there pop the [ __ ] vein
and [ __ ] my kid loves Disney in a whole
different [ __ ] way and so that movie
like haunted her for hours like [ __ ]
hours later I walked into my bedroom and
my daughter is bawling on the couch in
my wife's arms and I thought like her
and her boyfriend broke up I was like
what did he [ __ ] do and my wife goes
he is Christopher Robin
oh I know what he did yeah [ __ ] I saw
what he did I was like are you serious
like I can't get over it you know she
had a little stuffed animal she carried
around her whole life when she was kid
called yeah a little pink elephant flat
elephant and stuff and she named it
after J of all people and she couldn't
say J so she would say yeah yay
and so she named the elephant [ __ ]
yeah yeah so I didn't have something
like that that I carried around but like
I [ __ ] loved Winnie the Pooh and I
loved clever storytelling and I loved
the idea that like oh they let him grow
up and he had to find his friends again
and [ __ ] like that she was [ __ ]
devastated like still I looked at her
Instagram story the next day and it
looked like [ __ ] one of our beloved
animals had died she was just crying it
kept writing on the screen Christopher
Robin did this you know and [ __ ] like
that very [ __ ] emotional over the
whole affair man so it worked like crazy
on her my wife is like you're not
allowed to bring her to [ __ ] like that
anymore I was think it's not like I
brought into a horror movie where
somebody got killed or something like
that she was like I am not prepared to
give up two more hours to have a
Christopher Robin conversation about how
she can not feel bad about growing up
yeh still on her bed and [ __ ] like that
I was a kid nobody in this house has
ever had to let go of their childhood
even your 48 year old father still acts
like he's [ __ ] 12 so like like I get
it it works but like come on you can't
identify it with that much and stuff
this interesting I took my kids to the
movies what you see black Klansmen
likely it's depending on how you feel
about Spike Lee
it's a spike Lee movie so you know and
there's there's there's some of the
Spike Lee's that I love to death like
spike the spike is a I'm gonna reach for
it filmmaker and every turn and
sometimes those reaches are like Daffy
and weird and sometimes they're super
[ __ ] emotional and perfect and almost
abstract in their effectiveness he's an
artist he's an artist I you know my 14
year old son who does not have a ton of
like first-hand experience with the Klan
what kind of [ __ ] father are you come
on boy
the cross-burning sheds light it's cold
out here so like he was coming to it
almost totally cold like what is this
well son let me tell you about racism in
America according to Spike Lee and
luckily it's a spike spike paints the
Klan and suchlike broadly cartoonish
strokes yes that they're kind of Daffy
and laughable which is exactly how I
want to be explaining the Klan to a
14-year old it's like yes they're all
awful yes they're kind of dumb and
garish and stupidest [ __ ] and all of
their ethos --is make no kind of sense
but they're also a little bit funny but
not at all but like he could there's
enough distance like you're not
confronted by the real horrors of the
Klan that much in this movie because he
paints them also so broadly it's an
interest it's an interesting true story
I don't know if you are familiar with
said true story but the commercials kind
of tell you what it is which is there
was a black police officer of rookie in
the Colorado Springs Police Department
who one day like so and had in the
newspaper for the Klan and just calls
them and says hi I'm really interested
in your white supremacy movement can you
tell me more and they're like yes you
sound like you're down for the cause
like I am I hate [ __ ] and they're
like awesome and I just want to point
out the first use of that word was in
the last episode of fat man on Batman
ever
and that didn't good night everybody
my last episode a fan of Batman was
brought to you by the n-word and viewers
like you
[Laughter]
what heave ends decides that okay well
they want to meet me
we gotta infiltrate the Klan clearly I
can't go because I'm not Cleavon little
so I need a white guy to pretend to be
me and so he calls on kylo Ren kylo Ren
yeah
who's gotta like you know just he's like
I hate my parents hate all things and so
he's got to go undercover to all these
[ __ ] Klan meetings and this character
also happens to be Jewish and so which
that's apparently not there's a lot of
happening in this movie to movie so
first and foremost it's not supposed to
be like historically I'm sorry whatever
they tell you based on a true story
it means mostly fiction and some of this
might have happened but not all like
this so like it's but the parts that do
happen are kind of cool and kind of fun
and and there's parts this movie that
are very funny and then there's farce
those movie where you're like oh god
there's actually hate this kind of hate
which feels kind of baseless and
foundationless but exists in people's
hearts for reasons that I can't
adequately explain to my kid like why do
people hate people like this like I just
don't [ __ ] know buddy but hey
remember that Christopher Robin trailer
but it's no wait a second they trailered
Christopher Robin at the head of black
Klansmen really yeah I wonder what the
crossover in the Venn diagram is there
do you want to be angry and then we be
vice-versa but uh but Topher Grace is
actually remarkable in this movie plays
David is David Duke and there's this
kind of like blinkered idealism to him
which is kind of great but then you get
the spike enos of it like you get the
the dolly shots of people being brought
towards their final you know
confrontation you you get like long
monologues and people just kind of
sitting there telling you [ __ ]
I'll you know what man like Spike Lee of
course do the right thing is one of my
favorite top ten favorite movies of all
time it's brilliant [ __ ] movie and
and part of the reason I do what I do is
because I read spikes books and I love
Spike Lee as a filmmaker and you know I
know some people have issues with them
and whatnot scrape away whatever the
movies are about man's like Scorsese is
a true natural-born
filmmaker who constantly works at his
craft and stuff and and who was my point
in saying oh it sounds like a lot of
disclaimer but in China I'm wondering
what my point was in all that oh so that
being said I love that like if I'm
twenty five years into my career spike
is thirty thirty-five at this point I
may be at least thirty years into his
career
I love thirty years into his career he's
still committed to that dolly shot he's
sticking an actor on the dolly and
moving with it like he you know it was
his it was the first one that did at
least that I ever noticed in a movie and
some people hits him the wrong way and
[ __ ] but his unmistakeably his and it
doesn't matter how much money's have
whether he's that very little to make
the movie or all the money in the world
to make the movie he always includes a
variation of that shot I'd love that so
much that's somebody who's just like
this is mine this is one of my
signatures I know and I love that he's
now working with denzel's kid because I
don't know how often filmmakers get to
do that you know that guy's my muse as
is his progeny like I will find a way to
keep working with a Washington family
because they are my good luck charm they
always do
and John David Washington is a really
good actor it was a good he's really
good he's in ballers the only other time
I'd seen him is on HBO's Balaji that's
the show about foreign agents yes
starring the rock things that I'm least
interested in in life so I've never
watched it as a good show you know it's
it's it gets a bad rap for being like
entourage but with sports it's better
than now you just really unsold the show
to me is that what it is that's how they
get billed it at first because it's like
there's [ __ ] boys behaving badly with
lots and lots of money but it's it's got
a far more deft touch than entourage you
ever did the rock is a better actor than
anybody on Entourage you ever wonder who
I didn't realize I have you died ginger
and Grenier is the worst Aquaman
certainly more care certainly more
charismatic I would say than any of the
entourage leads and that's not [ __ ]
on those cats they obviously had enough
charm to make that show work for a long
[ __ ] time but admittedly Dwayne
Johnson is charming his [ __ ] there's a
reason that career just keeps [ __ ]
going remembering he made the Tooth
Fairy once any man I could keep a career
going after that like that's that's
charm man there's some people just have
that movie starred [ __ ] tone and that
dudes clearly one of those people and
that just keep working to then become
the biggest movie star on the planet
that takes doing and then also be like
I'm such a big movie star I'm gonna do
an HBO show sometimes like it's not even
his main [ __ ] gig you know kind of
crosses but ya know John John Washington
is the real deal so yeah I would we
start blowing the rock for a long time
we were talking about somebody
completely different you're right it's
fine but yeah like it's it's a really
interesting movie it is an interesting
slice of life it is it is a little too
overt when it doesn't need to be because
half the movie is like make America
great again jabs and like American it's
a period piece
it's a parody so it's in the 70s so
there's lots of [ __ ] hair
and lots of bell-bottoms and like John
Washington is working that fro and it's
a ton of [ __ ] froze but yeah there's
there's moments of that movie that
really sore and and one of my favorites
is he manages to get Harry Belafonte out
of retirement to do to just deliver like
this monologue as a dude who'd been a
victim of the sort of the the
Underground South the KKK had a best
friend it was lynched and just telling
the story of what it was like to be
terrorized in Alabama in like the 50s
and 60s and it's [ __ ] Harry Belafonte
and you just hear that voice and you see
that guy in that presence and the weight
of that man on film like whatever other
problems you might have with the movie
and there are problems to be had with
that movie every like 20 minutes
something that you would never have seen
anyplace else happens hmm and that for
me is kind of worth going to the movies
to see like I'd never saw that before
and I'm glad I did amen
I mean I was in I was gonna see it
eventually but you might have driven me
to the movie theater man every day or
four-day weekend whatever the [ __ ] it
was all my work was done then I was like
manufacturing work for myself so I went
and did another draft of Jay and Silent
Bob reboot this is the eighth draft of
the script and at this one this is weird
this is the draft where I had to take
out all the fat jokes because they just
don't make sense anymore so I that's
what I was working on and then I just
had enough time where I was like [ __ ] I
got no work what does one do and I was
like oh you used to go to the movies and
[ __ ] and it's the summer there should be
a bunch of stuff to say so you've just
added some to the list man OC good dig
into him here alright so is that it's
all the that is all the chitchat we
could check we got right on man this
show is divided it's bifurcated if you
will into two parts and in the first
part of the show we tasked mr. mark
barnard in here to go scour the internet
for all the news that might be [ __ ]
noteworthy to us so we can sit here and
digest it and break it down and whatnot
give it up for mark barnard and he went
and found some news
[Applause]
it's hard [ __ ] work out there man oh
you got to do it you're up there's your
mines you don't [ __ ] know you got to
go through a lot of it see what's fake
and what's real I do it that are you
familiar at all with a series of novels
and then a video game called The Witcher
oh no no no not at all
it is it is it is based on a massive
book series by a Polish author whose
name I will not attempt to pronounce
because it's got a lot of [ __ ]
consonants buttered up against each
other but it's about a a solitary Master
Hunter who struggles to find his place
in a world where people often prove more
wicked than beasts but when destiny
hurdles him toward a powerful sorceress
and a young princess with a dangerous
secret the three must learn to navigate
the increasingly volatile continents
with a capital C together it's gonna be
an eight episode series on Netflix we
mean continent with a capital C I think
that's just what they're calling there
were like middle-earth but now it's just
continent oh that's a typo on behalf of
deadline fair enough henry cavill will
be starring as sydney oh [ __ ] with or
without moustache i hope for [ __ ]
moustache i don't know which one I like
more now myself with or without
moustache I like the moustache yeah it
kind of worked I really do could be the
seed of his power I think they ought to
let him get one more [ __ ] shot at
Superman with the moustache I still
would love to see that footage because
it all exists somewhere of just awesome
you saw the hood that's right and you
know that footage is like like they
could just turn it into money at this
point and there are another passed it
enough where it's like come on man just
own it and show me that you give us the
stash give us the stash also sounds like
we're asking for the secret stash to
come back to LA yeah nobody's asking for
that we
just did though kind of a little bit
didn't our chance but yeah Henry Cavill
this will be his first TV role since the
tutors I loved him on the tutors that's
where I first saw me was Henry's best
friend Henry the eighth yeah but that's
where I first noticed him then Oh like
this cat's gonna be Superman so he's
going back to TV he's gonna be a [ __ ]
fantasy monster slayer with stache I'm
gonna say it [ __ ] it he's got a mustache
who's doing it
Netflix in episodes straight to series
probably out in 2019 if I had to guess
but sometimes when 21e how do you know
yeah [ __ ] 2019 you had the same article
he did feel like I read one line further
than Marc seems like everyone's got a
Netflix show except us I know it kind of
sucks
look I'm used to being never put being
part of the popular crowd though so that
it really doesn't affect me does it
bother you at all it does a little bit
man doesn't really I like to be popular
all evidence of the contrary I don't
mind I like getting paid so yeah all the
money
so yeah that's happening hey gonna make
it a Swamp Thing series yeah JDC
all-access yeah James was one is is
creative a creative but he'll probably
direct an episode
they hired a director for the pilot is
is not James Watt is it Kevin Smith I
don't know are we breaking new news God
be amazing who is it who's got the job
your old buddy Len Wiseman what a great
choice yeah he did underworld he didn't
he did a movie I was in he directed man
live free or die hard
he did indeed yeah he's a good call man
he you know Len has an interesting
career he started in what props and then
moved to production design and from
there went to directing you rarely
[ __ ] see that but his idea he brought
came up with the idea for underworld and
stuff so he got to make
moving them BAM he became a director
he's a nice [ __ ] dude he then won I
knew absolutely I mean it's been a few
years since I've seen him and you know
[ __ ] it would change who knows but
like he was a really nice dude good guy
yeah I mean he was the furthest apropos
of nothing but he was the first adult I
knew that texted with a child and that
sound I should explain that because it
sounds dirty and [ __ ] but he had a
stepdaughter who was young she was like
11 or 12 and he like one day we were
chitchat and he goes hold on and he's
text and he was laughing it shows what
were you doing he's like I'm texting
with it was Kate Beckinsale's kid and I
thought I was adorable I was like you
text with him with a teenager you know
was that like and he's like you'll find
out one day and I did now I texted my
kid all the time where I'm like you
[ __ ] shut up about Christopher Robin
Jesus what Len Wiseman on Swamp Thing
gets my vote I'm all for that he's also
made a pretty handy career out of
directing pilots for TV shows he did he
did Hawaii five-o he did Lucifer did he
do the Wi-Fi you did Lucifer as well oh
[ __ ] well the first one what was the
first one you mentioned Sleepy Hollow
that lends itself probably to the
direction that they're going with Swamp
Thing so yeah he's really good choice
yeah but then there's there's money to
be made being that guy because if you
Dan Len Wiseman being the guy who
directs the pilot of a TV show if you're
gonna direct any episode of a TV show
direct the pilot man then they give you
a little scratch going forward and say I
really do because nine times out of ten
if you're at that level you then attach
yourself as an executive producer to the
show and then you get paid every time
they have an episode of that show as an
executive producer whether you show up
or do anything or not yeah and some of
that sweet consultant money yeah and I
wonder what that I don't know I made
that sound dirty I know yeah
all right so I'm down like a clown as no
kids today say for that for that idea
hey hey fellow youths I have more DC
Universe news okay DC Universe the app
DC University app their programming grid
there this [ __ ] they're doing
tell me about it because I know nothing
about this I am sure you know our friend
he of the two Knicks Alan Tudyk yes has
been cast in Doom Patrol oh [ __ ] I
didn't know this alright wait hold on
let me let me guess old okay so if you
get we know that I'm going to do it by
process a process of elimination
we know that cliff has been cast as
brandon fraiser
as cliff steel robot man yes
he's obviously you know not Elastigirl
no nor is he crazy Jane he's not crazy
Jane though Chris Jane's a character in
this burg yep okay so that leaves Larry
Trainor the negative man and not cyborg
clearly cyborg is into him patrol since
when they made a do virtual show
interesting yeah hmm Who am I forgetting
oh wait Niles Caulder the chief no he's
too young for that
all right I don't know he will be
playing Eric Morden slash mr. nobody oh
I have deep feelings about yeah
[Applause]
good for a storyline they did is he a
bad guy or something
ah let's see bla bla bla after explosion
to make memories of ex-nazis in post-war
Paraguay the man formerly known as Erik
Morden emerges as a living shadow able
to drain the sanity of others as the
enigmatic and totally insane mr. nobody
so maybe bad guy may be good for some
reason I think but maybe but I'm rusty
am i Doom Patrol but oh [ __ ] what an
amazing run of that book it was a grant
Morrison did right [ __ ] it was just so
next-level [ __ ] and I'm really wonderful
and right now they're doing it again
right a gerard ways young animals doing
a bunch of doing things that might have
been the one book to survive i think
they cancelled much of the young animal
laws that do patrol survive so maybe it
sounds like this is the version of the
Doom Patrol that they're actually doing
wouldn't surprise me at all I'm in I
[ __ ] I love the fact I said it on
their stream on the DC Universe stream I
love the fact that they're like [ __ ] it
we don't need a other networks to pick
up our shows anymore if we want to do a
Doom Patrol show we'll do it on an arm
app and stuff it's nice that they're
taken the reins of their own material
and not just leaving it up to chance
hoping some network will roll the dice
on that they like [ __ ] it we'll roll the
dice on so we're getting a Swamp Thing
show a Doom Patrol show that's really
exciting how often do you stop by the DC
daily streaming thing yeah today I was
on deck for the premiere episode and
stuff but no I'm like him when we it was
wonderful I had a great time doing the
show and stuff and they were like oh my
god you got to come back and stuff but
when the show was over at one point
we're all on stage like group shot we
all took a picture together and like all
right Kevin step out just the cast and I
was like fine
so so like all those people I introduced
there the DC Daly hosts and stuff but I
they wanted me to come back to do other
stuff so is so I'll be probably back
alright last news story and what they're
doing on that channel too which is
genius
just long long deep dives on characters
doing documentaries on their characters
so like I sat down for
an interview for an Aquaman documentary
in Shazam documentary naturally makes
sense because they got those movies
coming out and stuff but they told me a
bunch of the other characters that
they're doing and it's not the standard
like Batman it's just like they're going
into their treasure trove and they're
like having people like talk about the
characters and their memories and [ __ ]
like that
like so right up my alley I would
totally watch this show where I not in
it and if I weren't in it I would call
someone up and be like why aren't I in
this [ __ ] thing and stuff so I got to
sit down and do the interview they got
all their shows are like right up my
alley and one and and the they showed on
the app or on that the the live stream
we did for the DC Universe the intro to
their movies like when they put up a
movie they have like people introduce it
and [ __ ] yeah so I know I haven't done
one but they asked me to do when I was
like I'll do one in a heartbeat but I
know some people who have done them and
it's it's it's just I don't know the
retreating it so cool this is everything
that I would have loved back when I was
a [ __ ] kid collecting DC Comics and
[ __ ] like oh my god and I'm an adult now
who obviously still loves this [ __ ] and
I can't [ __ ] wait like it's one thing
like my kids one of the anchors on DC
daily so I love it for that reason where
I'm like thank God somebody else is
paying this [ __ ] kid and so I'm happy
about that but I'm just happy as a
[ __ ] fan they're aggregating a lot of
[ __ ] under one roof and it's smart cool
might it also might give us a [ __ ]
job one day man you know you know took
kid I wouldn't say no last news story is
a little bit incestuous I think in a way
okay in that Disney has announced that
for their new Star Wars land Star Wars
Galaxies edge yes they will for the
first time sell alcohol I saw this in
the part that isn't at club 33 that
isn't it you know whatever that other
Ben California Adventure look I I mean I
but they've from what I understand
they've kept it out of the park for as
long as they have because that was one
of Walt's like dictums Walt was like no
booze and Disneyland
right and so there never has been but
Disneyworld they got booze at Epcot cuz
they like hey technically Walt never
said no booze at Epcot you know so
buggin
and as the Walt Disney Museum taught me
he's dead
yeah so yeah so they I don't know if
they'll you know I I doubt they'll
change the policy and Disneyland proper
that just feels like it's now you know
kind of woven into the fabric of that
Park yes but doing Star Wars land
ironically enough like gives them the
opportunity I never would have put those
two things together like Star Wars
licorice but like I guess they're right
there was a there was a cantina bar out
of cantina yeah how interesting what a
novel concept to make a bar that looks
like a thing that was in a movie I mean
somebody should do that I should it's a
good idea man yeah there's money to be
made I think it's yeah I mean that'd be
ironic if one day they like come to your
show here JC I'm sorry we're gonna we
gotta step out on you a little bit
everything's so familiar but more
expensive I look I'm not gonna you know
prick the future like Babe Ruth pointing
to [ __ ] left-field and [ __ ] but I
will say this the theme bar I think will
only become like a bigger concept it's
fun right well I mean look you're gonna
walk in someplace to get a [ __ ] drink
like for years it look like [ __ ]
Friday's and [ __ ] like that just like
wood or brick or whatever the [ __ ] and
funny [ __ ] hanging on the wall wouldn't
like I'm not a drinker I'm a STONER but
if this was a [ __ ] smoking bar I
would come here man [ __ ] that'd be
like like oh my god if I'm gonna get
high anywhere it's in this [ __ ] room
like cuz then I'm in the movies you know
and I'm saying
so I think it's an idea that like
catches on in a big bad way I went to a
place I met a guy who had a themed bar
at a video store bar so he walked in to
the front and it looked like a little
video store with all VHS is you can
literally rent VHS from and I was like
why would you start this business like
this late in the game like I get the
kitchen of a remember VHS but you're
gonna go broke and hungry and [ __ ] and
then they pull the [ __ ] video on the
wall and I open it up and there's a
speakeasy behind it they're like this
where the money is [ __ ] you know
he also had a bar that was themed to the
Overlook Hotel see that's like a cool
[ __ ] concept man Lloyd your ghostly
bartender and [ __ ] like that so a notion
of like a watering hole that feels like
something you know and SCHIP gives you
that distinct impression I could see
that totally catching on it's no brainer
that they did it like if you're building
Star Wars land which again like sounds
[ __ ] astounding sounds like something
seven year old me nine year old me who
saw those movies when they happened
dreamed of like oh is there a hotel
where we go pretend we're in [ __ ]
Star Wars now you will go there and you
can't even wear this [ __ ] when you show
up you got to put on their fake outfits
and walk around and you're you're like
it's taken a movie to the next level
where you're like now you're in the
[ __ ] thing so it makes sense that
they're like hey and we got a bar too
and you could drink blue milk or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah man I you know
I'll visit it when they put a Star Wars
weed bar in and I'm [ __ ] there like
crazy and stuff oh like you're not gonna
go go visit once you get weed or
opening-day oh man like if I would go
open and day unless it was like hey man
you're part of the guest list and I'm
like oh [ __ ] I ought to wait in line cuz
like the line would kill it for me man
because I'm like look I know another
Star Wars like bar somewhere where I get
in like that
you got to come correct you got to show
me some incredible [ __ ] is Jabba there
if not [ __ ] off man I'm staying in
Hollywood well that's pretty tremendous
man is that all the news all the news a
slow news week hopefully it'll happen
soon well I know what we'll be talking
about on the next edition tomorrow at
this time we will have all seen the
Captain Marvel trailer so next week
we're gonna have a ton of [ __ ] to talk
about on next episode but in the
meantime the news is that an end ladies
and gentlemen get about for mark barnard
and he brought you the news we caught
something we've got some got some got
some news all right now that we're all
[ __ ] informed and [ __ ] it's time to
get informed in a different way second
part of this show ladies and gentlemen
is the QA aspect of this show the QA
allows you folks in the audience to jump
up to the mic take the spotlight and ant
spotlight and ask hold on and ask
questions that you wanna you want to get
answers for and stuff like that and so
what we do is if you ask questions that
are useful to both of us the questions
should be addressed addressable to both
me and mark and stuff we get a good
answer out of us we got some tickets
here that we're gonna give you as a free
gift from the good folks at 40x man
Deacon Brett Deacon who's not here
tonight God has tickets yet again give
it up for Deacon even though he's not
really bad
the 4dx experience ladies and gentlemen
is a fun [ __ ] way to watch a movie if
it's snowing in the movie it's snowing
in the movie theater and [ __ ] if
somebody is screeching away on a [ __ ]
motorcycle you smell burnt rubber and
stuff during the credits to a Star Wars
movie your chair goes back as the
[ __ ] words crawl up the screen it's
pretty phenomenal they have a theater at
LA live here in Los Angeles there are
theaters all over I think is in New York
there's also in Chicago as well but the
one we always point people to is LA live
so we got five sets of tickets here
two tickets apiece so you're not walking
in going like one please you get to walk
in somebody else man if you're smart you
take mark barnard because then he leans
over he's like he's
got emotional baggage and then I just
and then your chair shudders because it
too is so shocked you didn't see that
okay so five sets of [ __ ] tickets man
we open it up to JC the is the guy who
runs this year fine establishment we
should we identify we did not we were so
busy blowing the last episode of fat man
I'm Batman
we forgot to say where we are man here
we are scum and villainy Cantina on
Hollywood Boulevard Hollywood California
the only space themed bar you actually
need JC runs this year bar and he's
picked our first person we're gonna
speak to and he's standing up and you
got an appropriate shirt on what's your
name young man my name is grant
what is it grant grant everyone give it
up for grant what that you're gonna take
us someplace and if you take us there
correctly you're getting rewarded with
these tickets
okay so all the way here from Washington
right I was worried
Washington's tri-cities Washington
Charlotte all my friends they watch it
hey friends so we always have these big
fights of if we had a group of super
heroes super villains who would we pick
and why so I would I was hoping what do
you could do like a softball or a tee
ball kind of pick one and the other
super heroes villains top five who's
your favorite heroes favorite villains
and then who do you think would win wow
that's like a multi-part math question
right there it's like doing algebra
asked you I'm sorry all right so let's
say so should we so am i doing villains
when you're doing heroes who ever wants
to who do you want to do villains or
heroes
I'll do I'll do I'll do villains okay I
would say any fictional character
doesn't have to be just comments
doesn't have to be comic no cinematic
comic-book anything man you pulled the
good category cuz villains are way more
interesting the heroes now I got to work
very hard okay
I don't know we trying to game this to
see which would win in a fight my league
of villains versus his League of Heroes
yes
fair enough I'm gonna win gone ones been
laid I just said I so I've really read
here what I should be doing here is
strategic I shouldn't even be picking my
favorites I should be picking the most
powerful and [ __ ] like that number one
Jesus I thought he would say it that's
all right you cannot kill your teammate
if this Jesus man it just keeps coming
back and [ __ ] Jesus yeah it takes three
days but still just bear in mind my
dad's gonna watch this he's a retired
pastor he's only gonna be around for a
little bit true it's true
alright so Jesus number one do i direct
do I go down yeah we'll go back and
forth so Jesus I gotta beat Jesus good
luck many have tried now like religion
is on the table pick Pontius Pilate I
was gonna go Satan Shaw go say ma but he
beat Satan Satan's like I could give you
the world he's like my dad owns the
world [ __ ] off
yeah but one of them are still here
[Music]
just saying yeah we just lost the
Christian audience okay okay Jesus say
yes Batman because Jesus you know is
your might but [ __ ] Batman is your
right uppercuts and [ __ ] like okay
Batman will break somebody's [ __ ]
spine Batman taxes something even Batman
has to fight like as Batman I fight
injustice because Bruce Wayne I fight
high taxes let's see okay taxes
I got yeah this axis Batman who do I add
tea
controversial choice okay
Thanos from a certain perspective he's a
hero he could have literally wiped out
everybody with one snap I call that
mercy let's see so think about it now
I've got Jesus
I've got Batman and I've got the
Infinity Gauntlet what do you got man
[Music]
[Applause]
well played all right let's see I got
Jesus Batman fan oohs the good one I
mean there's so many that I want to
reach for that you know are like obvious
but like you know if I can I got to get
more creative you pass you go I'll think
of one
don't say the NRA
mr. Mixel plate ooh and him well done
magic sit play oh [ __ ] Harry Potter
the Boy Who Lived man he's always
rubbing it in Jesus's face alright so uh
so now we're still at for each where for
each so now do I have to go first
because you passed I'll go again alright
so I've got Jesus Batman good Thanos and
Harry Potter it's need another much the
five-year-old in me wants to pick jaws
I saw him as the hero of that movie
let's see oh well I want to pick this
but I want you to just copy me and [ __ ]
do it go ahead do it do it do it
Darth Vader okay
he went good eventually at the end of
that story for like eight minutes yes
it's a good eight minutes man so what
you got is the best of all possible
worlds like a [ __ ] killing machine
who spends his life [ __ ] taking lives
who at the very end was like now I like
people swing so like he's maybe there's
even prowess or him Christensen trouser
Christensen ah
can I pick whoever played him in [ __ ]
rogue one sure I'm picking that Darth
Vader that Darth Vader but he's my
friend
alright I got five who you got five my
last one is I'm tempted to go big but
big isn't that much fun okay I'm going
to go sore on the blinky I of death know
the bad taste in jewelry
Maximillian from the black hole what the
[ __ ]
did you do it just to [ __ ] with me oh my
god what a great [ __ ] nostalgic
choice why he's [ __ ] powerless he
survives the end of the [ __ ] world
the inside out of that black hole like
you see him surviving perdition's flames
that [ __ ] can do almost anything
alright fair enough man but Jesus beats
him who do you think send them into that
black hole Harry alright pick your pick
your character who's up first
woah that's a good time no that's good
luck what is pick a character who's he
putting up first
you wanna put enough first Thanos I put
up Thanos we negate each okay white
round 1 done fast wins Jesus who's your
next guy who do I put up saving him for
closing back you don't bleed with Jesus
you close with Jesus exactly Batman
Batman's my [ __ ] second act with five
acts Mixel plate [ __ ] but Batman has
beaten emp'd before he's got experience
with bat-mite so it could be a decent
fight okay I don't know who wins in that
one got to give it to you right alright
magic wins mix afflict beats Batman does
anybody know story where Batman in his
face mix up lick and beat him you just
have to give him say his name backwards
[ __ ] you Batman wins he's so smart he
would be like you know slipping in and
suddenly mugger guy and then he
disappears let's see third when I put up
Harry Potter taxes you win Harry Potter
can't be taxes man Gringotts is a [ __ ]
that one yeah goddamn muggle world
yeah yeah it does work all right so who
do I got left my deep been Chad Vader
and Jesus
Vader's up fourth man he's my
penultimate move who's uh who's he up
against um who do I have left
Satan and Maximilian from the black hole
choose wisely Satan Satan against fuggin
against Darth Vader yeah I guess see for
most of the time Darth Vader wins into
the last eight minutes and [ __ ] like
Satan's like boom but then he comes back
as you won't go a little some of this
was your fantasy Vader am i well where
are we first ones negated so it's really
best of four right so you've got mixed
up Lincoln Batman mixed look at Batman
which taxes and Potter and so far your
two was this next one we did Satan Vader
vs Satan Vader has to win this match or
I lose completely sure although I do
clean up with Jesus Jesus is like you
want to see a snap [ __ ] I don't
know who wins between mix up licking
Batman anybody know wait what was the
what's the one who wins - invader and
Satan let go I kind of think Satan wins
but I am my beep ray mater comes back as
the force the living force and Satan's
like the floor so the forces just
[ __ ] midi-chlorians [ __ ] you yeah
hang out on [ __ ] bonfires you didn't
do anything just exert barbecue here
what what's the last one Jesus vs.
Maximilian yes yeah
/ yeah I think mark wins man and you win
tickets give it up for our excellent
question well done my champion all right
Jason take is there where you wanna go
man somebody else must have a question
for us to ask and there's a bunch of
shirts they want you sign right there
hey what's your name hey guys my name is
Anand Anand Arnold
onam thank you sibel a n a nd a and on
on and on and on and give it up for
Anand man how are you good sir what can
we possibly do for you this evening
uh first off I'm gonna be that guy every
podcast that just like talks about you
guys for a bit clearly as you might have
guessed I didn't grow up here Cleveland
I was thinking Ireland but you're right
Cleveland so I am I'm from India I grew
up in Dubai and one of the things is we
didn't have comic book stores out there
for the longest time so a lot of how I
got into comics was either friends or
Wikipedia and at one fine day I sort of
stumbled upon to the podcast so you sort
of introduced me to or at least and you
just made a lot of facts about comics
you told me that like Luke Skywalker was
the Joker for some reason I didn't
realize that until you mentioned that on
Episode two so in my god how amazing
what a weird wonderful world you live in
where one day somebody late in life was
like you know Luke Skywalker
he's also the Joker
anyone pretty much I was listening to
that episode now is like why is Luke
Skywalker here it's supposed to be about
Batman and then like he does the voice
in like I know this voice what the hell
so and like I've sorta been listening
since like ever since you know I had a
long time to where I went to school so
that's usually when I would listen to
the only episodes I would kind of skip
were the you know commentaries on movies
them like I don't have you know I can't
really watch while driving so you know
I'd skip a lot of those then you started
the utility belt section and that's when
you sort of start having mark on the
show and less guests and how's the who
is this mark Barnard in guy why are
there no guests anymore what like what
is happening I like we went from Paul
Dini to like the guy who was on all the
episodes I skipped and I kept listening
and I realize that I agreed a lot more
with mark than anyone else so so again
yeah I guess what I'm coming to is the
two of you sort of embody these two
messages where Kevin you were kind of
like no matter what you do and no matter
how old you get don't be afraid to love
the things you love like I watch Justice
League twice in theaters people like
still give me [ __ ] about that and I
realized that it's not the best movie
but like when Superman holds back at the
entire Justice League you cannot not be
amazed at that at that one seat you know
and you never have to apologize for
[ __ ] loving something full-out like
[ __ ] even if the other people like
really that [ __ ] man like [ __ ] it
don't matter it's like it's how it
affects you all this shit's subjective
right and it's nice when we're all on
the same page where it's like we love
infinity war and stuff but like everyone
has a different [ __ ] journey I could
sit here and do hours on [ __ ]
buckaroo banzai and some people are like
oh that movie blah blah blah but it
doesn't change the fact that like I
adore glad [ __ ] you
love Justice League and paid to see it
twice I'm not the only one thank Christ
I like watching that movie on iTunes
because I'll be going through my iTunes
and the artwork for it is so [ __ ]
colorful and I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
take the journey and then ten minutes in
I'm like aw [ __ ]
and so I stay with the journey and
whatnot and there are moments in it that
like really do it for me and whatnot but
you know it's it's it doesn't have the
same impact for me that like the Chris
Nolan's stuff had but I love when people
are like hey man that's my religion like
it's a reminder that like every movie is
somebody's favorite [ __ ] movie you
know even the ones that like you know
you'll sit there and be like yeah it
could have been better
yeah and well that's the message that
you embody mark on the other hand is he
just shits on everything so I was gonna
say is what I've got from you is more of
just because you love something don't be
afraid to critique it don't be afraid to
point out flaws because that's the only
way things are gonna get better and and
this is kind of why I feel that the two
of you thinking right now
you guys make such a great team and I
guess I want to thank you for everything
that you for putting on the show for not
just from myself from everyone here and
most importantly from everyone around
the world who might not be able to see
you in person just thank you for being
you
number one that's awesome I love to be
part of somebody's journey into comics
somebody was my journey into comics Walt
Flanagan and stuff so I know what that
means some to have somebody simply
explain some [ __ ] that you weren't
around when it happened but quickly it
becomes your religion so I know how
special it is being on that journey
thanks for letting us be a part of yours
that's really [ __ ] cool that God look
where it's taking you aim higher is all
I can say
so yeah thanks to both you and thanks to
JC - because obviously without you know
you and the bar at this also home so
thanks to you - I agree everyone give it
up for JC scum and villainy okay now for
a set of these [ __ ] what do you
got okay it's kind of a two-part
question the first part is I know you
guys both are started out doing
commentaries on movies but have you ever
considered doing like a let's play a
video on any of the games either the
Arkham games or the spider-man game
coming out soon or anything like that is
that something that you guys have
considered or would like to do at some
point somebody has asked me I forget
where it was it might have been on
talked salad and scrambled eggs with
math Meyer or that we talked about me
playing the Arkham games all the way
through cuz he loves the [ __ ] games
and he was like oh my god you would love
it he's going the storylines and you're
definitely would and I told them I was
like I've watched most of the cutscenes
like up on online so the only thing I'm
missing is the actual punching people in
the face part he's like that's the best
[ __ ] partner so we've talked about
doing it sooner or later that should be
an episode we do where we sit down I'd
like to sit down with like somebody
who's amazing rather than me because it
would be embarrassing to watch Batman
fall off the roof that many [ __ ]
times but to sit down with a true master
and [ __ ] and walk through the game like
I'm not one of those people it's like I
got a play I'm happy to watch somebody
do it particularly because the new video
games seem a lot more like movies you
know where you can go through an entire
[ __ ] storyline so but it takes hours
right like you can't just do it in two
hours can you probably speedrun but then
that's kind of not that much fun to
watch somebody just blaze through it all
without anything but me maybe it's a
maybe it's a limited series of the all
we spent four episodes games you get
blazed and I play a game and we then
drop it onto the world all right I'm
down we'll get there
you've sold us we're there can't wait to
see that and I guess the second part of
the question is what DC or marvel IP
would you guys want to be a game and
what kind of game would that be what DC
or marvel IP would I like to see be a
game or what game would that be I got a
thought go I think using something like
either the roller coaster tycoon engine
or maybe the minecraft engine a damage
control game where you have to rebuild
New York after every [ __ ] huge giant
like this put his foot in the middle of
Central Park how do we rebuild it and
you've got a certain amount of resources
and you can [ __ ] build and allocate
and you're allocating versus
crime-fighting versus rebuilding versus
triage I think there is there some kind
of weird granular giant MMORPG builder
thing you could do with that IP that a
14 year old would endlessly play for
like two months and I'm like oh [ __ ]
fortnight is back and then disappear
down a well
but yeah that'd be kind of fun I was
gonna say Groot pong so I like his heads
are much better man that's kind of smart
you can go deep on that game let me see
what would I like to see based on a
storyline that I've enjoyed in the
comics Secret Wars but I'm sure they've
done that haven't they already done a
Secret Wars game if that what seriously
are you that's the easiest [ __ ]
Marvel game to do it's like all these
heroes have to [ __ ] fight each other
or else like and I know they have
don't they have a marvel
fight each other right just call [ __ ]
Secret Wars oh [ __ ] that's easy I'm
gonna title on an old game exactly
exactly
uh yeah I'd go for Secret Wars that make
the most sense to me great question you
win tickets give it up for ArmA ladies
and gentlemen rise you're all right Jay
see what we got next where we're gone
hey hey what's your name Katie and we
give it up for Katie
[Applause]
how are you Katie what can we do you for
I'm good so I have two questions for you
and I really hate when people do this on
the podcast but it's okay yeah yeah he
did it so it's okay he's from India and
I'm from Texas and so it's I don't know
we're both third-world countries that's
more offensive welcome to the other
America thank you thank you for welcome
back to California welcome to the bubble
so here's my first question that you
guys have both have good ideas about
alternative storylines what happens why
do those storylines not get developed
into movies are they because there's not
enough time to come up with them
creatively is there not enough money to
make them into movies or is there just
the lack of creativity
you mean our specific like hey I wish
they would have done that to that thing
yeah I mean that's just fun that's
arm-chair directing right like it's
always easiest to be like you know what
you could have done and it's also like
you know as somebody who not only makes
the [ __ ] but talks about other people's
[ __ ] like it's weird because I know as a
filmmaker I hate when people are like
well if you had done this this and this
and like if I had done that it wouldn't
be me so I got to do me and if you don't
like it you know I don't know what to
tell you in [ __ ] so there's a part of me
that feels like oh [ __ ]
like don't tell me what to do but then
we sit here and some of the best times
I've ever had on the show is when he's
like you know it would make it better
and he throws something in there and
[ __ ] you just ruined the movie for all
time and [ __ ] so you know there's a
school of thought that says talk about
what you're presented as opposed to what
you dreamed you were gonna get and stuff
like that so whenever I go see a movie
that's what I try to do I like on this
show how you know we could sit there and
[ __ ] spit ball and he comes up with
[ __ ] cooler things he's just better
about story than I am in general so like
he can whip out alts or something that
had [ __ ] blow my mind you just saw it
before when he was like luggage bichos
there watching that movie for two hours
never once is it occur I've never go
beyond the surface I'm all [ __ ] text
subtext is for smarter people so for me
I like it's it's a weird position to be
in
I just think it's easiest and way easier
to tell people what they did wrong than
it is to just start from scratch and do
something right like at the end of the
day like we all liked where I assume
most of us like infinity warrant [ __ ] we
were on the same page of what the Russo
brothers done did but it could have went
so horribly wrong where we were like
what the [ __ ] and [ __ ] and then it
would've been easy to poke fun it like
you know like as much as we were just
talking about it like Justice League
it's very easy movie to sit there and be
like they could have done this and they
could have done this and stuff I think
in the case of that movie if you go
movie by movie basis like you know we
know what the problems were there that
movie had two parents and like neither
of them we're really talking to each
other I guess and two different movies
kind of come together so it's easier on
something like that to be like they
could have done this I don't know I
think ultimately you know people pick
their direction and head in it and
sometimes doesn't match with what could
have been done or what we wanted it to
be but but that's it it's not budget
they got all the money in the world to
do all this [ __ ] so it's certainly not
that I think it just comes down to they
make choices that aren't exactly in sync
with the audience but think about how
vast the [ __ ] audio
says it'd be impossible to give
everybody what they want
it's a miracle when a movie you know or
TV show gives enough people I was
thinking about today like you know hear
about it like a lot of [ __ ] only certain
[ __ ] breaks through anymore stranger
things it's one of those things that
like [ __ ] broke through man we're
like everybody my mother knows stranger
things and stuff and nobody really has
any Corrections for it but like you know
other stuff we can't easily be like and
I would change this I would change this
I think it has more to do with choices
though we these storytellers go in
certain direction now since the audience
is so vast so much more vast than the
audience has ever been before there are
enough different voices out there that
can be like well you could have done
this you could have done this and I'm
rambling you I mean I think that the
other element that is often in short
supply it's not money because they've
got hundreds of millions dollars to
spend on saying that all the money they
don't have time because half the time
what ends up happening is that they will
decide the release date before they have
a script with every cast over them a
director like we need to have this movie
out July 4th 2021 and if that movie is
ready or not or good or not it needs to
be out because there's an entire
stockholders shareholders [ __ ]
happening we got toy lines running up we
got Happy Meals happening that merch
all of it is colliding with a date on a
calendar that has not been decided upon
by the filmmakers who's got to be like
we might not be ready no you have to be
ready there's got to be a movie that's
what happened with Justice League if you
remember like Batman V Superman came out
and you know the reaction was like wow
this is kind of dark and they literally
went to make Justice League the weekend
after it opened like they were all off
went to Europe and started shooting the
movie no time to course-correct
like he couldn't like they would have to
shut down not hit their start date in
order to be like we're gonna do a
different script or a different approach
or change things or something and
instead they were like we got a hit a
date [ __ ] it moving forward and stuff
and then what did they do they wound up
trying to course-correct later on so
yeah he's right that has a lot to do
with it
and the schedule and stuff people just
relax yeah it might be able to come up
with like like those Marvel movies man I
hate to I'm not I'm not pitting the two
against each other but they certainly
seem to start building them way the [ __ ]
out you know it's not like we started
the movie like two minutes ago and it's
coming out in six months like they've
been planning this [ __ ] for a decade or
something like that they told us years
ago they were like here's how we're
gonna roll these movies out like yeah if
you ever get there and we're [ __ ]
there man so like clearly they were they
had a plan going to mind and we know
that you know Justice League was a
little bit kind of haphazard and stuff
it looks like they're cleaning their act
up over there not that it was [ __ ]
dirty to be cleaned up but Aquaman looks
[ __ ] flawless the trailer looks
[ __ ] flawless looks like everything
an action-adventure comic-book movie
needs to be in fact it looks more than
we've ever seen before they're showing
me [ __ ] I ain't seen before so I'm like
who looks like they learned something
and now I've watched that Shazam trailer
like 10 [ __ ] times and it is Charm
City if that movie doesn't make money
man I'll leave my [ __ ] hat because at
the end of the day it is appealing to
the one audience that they've seemed to
forget in all this [ __ ] not just the
movie makers but like the game makers
the TV [ __ ] makers the comic book
makers kids like it needs to start with
kids it has to believe you have to the
only reason we still talk about this
[ __ ] the only reason like I leave my
house at age 48 and come out on a
[ __ ] Tuesday night to sit around and
talk about this [ __ ] is because as a
child I was infected and it has grown
with me man and like it outlives [ __ ]
that didn't last as long I was raised
Catholic you don't hear me out there
talking about Jesus that much you know
unless i'm building a super team but
then then he's very useful but like this
[ __ ] takes root in childhood and like
that's that movie looks like it's aimed
squarely at the heart of a [ __ ] kid
like and the approach is you know it's
not insanely novel don't like hey man
it's big with superheroes [ __ ] it
I'll take it I just want to see hook
with Winnie the Pooh so like I'll
[ __ ] take a mix-up anyway you do it
I'm there for him stuff I think there
back on the right track they seem to
know what they're doing now yeah like
all we're doing here is is giving a
third draft to a script that never got
one you know because they don't have
time like where we're iterating we're
like hey but what if you hey what if you
that's all like being a writer
especially in the writers room is is
like like but what if we also did this
hey that's great what if we also did
this what if we tried that it's being
able to experiment and figure it out and
throw [ __ ] away when it doesn't work I
mean that's why Pixar has had such a for
the most part unbroken string of good
movies even the shittiest ones are
better than the other shitty movies it's
because of throwing stuff away they
threw away the entirety of Toy Story 2
yeah when it just didn't work they're
like I'm sorry this isn't happening for
us well it wasn't that it didn't work
they were making a straight-to-video
Toy Story sequel and Steve Jobs jumped
in was like are you out of your [ __ ]
minds like we just built something
nobody else has ever seen gonna waste it
on a straight-to-video
[ __ ] scrap it and you know he's
known to be or they've written books
about what a [ __ ] guy he was how he
was very do it my way or the highway but
he was absolutely right like they would
have killed that [ __ ] brand forever
if they were like hey man now on home
video Tory story to the cheap adventurer
you know instead he was like hold that
shit's gotta be specials gotta be in a
movie theater and it kind of worked out
and stuff you know and I just came to
mind somebody just told me this and I'm
like that makes [ __ ] sense like I've
been talking about like I'm involved in
this thing that I've been working on and
hopefully it goes to series and blah
blah blah I still can't talk about it
but the cats that I work with you know
I've been in a business 25 years and I
haven't always worked just for myself
sometimes I used to work for other
people and stuff and when you work for
other people you're subject to taking
their [ __ ] notes you take their money
here and take their [ __ ] bills
so back in the day and I told story many
times about working on Superman had to
take the [ __ ] notes in the story I
tell about it's like these people that
gave me notes for ridiculous and stupid
and [ __ ] like that and generally that
seems to be the case out here when
people get notes from a studio though oh
it's [ __ ] terrible it ruined it I've
just been going through an experience
and the same
don't listen to podcasts because don't
help my cause at all and [ __ ] but I was
[ __ ] blown away flabbergasted by
[ __ ] like the the quality of the notes
that I got on the thing that I was
involved with the thing I'm involved in
we're so [ __ ] good the jump between
he read it first draft and second draft
was everything and I never would have
gotten there if I didn't get [ __ ]
strong notes and [ __ ] like that so I was
like I was talking to the kids going
like what you know I kept blowing them
up going like guys give me [ __ ] good
no it's like if this thing happens
it's literally because you guys have
[ __ ] guided me every step of the way
like I'm just drunk and [ __ ] like that
like her this way this way this way
you're good and she like that so I said
what is that man and they told me
they're back in the day when I first
started the job your execs and [ __ ] like
that
I don't know who they were but nowadays
they're all writers like everyone that
I'm in a room with is a writer as well
so I'm not answering to some [ __ ]
suit it's all creative so when you're
getting notes you're getting notes from
other [ __ ] writers and stuff blew my
[ __ ] hair back and they told me
that's the way they do it at Pixar they
call it the Pixar method I was like what
do you mean they like Pixar was the
first company to do that we're instead
of hiring creative execs who aren't
[ __ ] writers they were like we're
just gonna hire writers they're like you
know how many writers are in this
business they're not working [ __ ] it
come work here and make [ __ ] better so
like talk about stacking the deck man
like no just like but what a wonderful
job it is like even if you're not like
writing your own [ __ ] thing you can
go work at the magic factory where you
could [ __ ] like make [ __ ] better and
whatnot on this just blew my hair back
and stuff so in any event he's right
more time would certainly [ __ ] help
but in some cases you know it's a
business right like at the end of the
day we love it because it's like hey and
this shit's our religion but to a bunch
of other people over the hill and this
is not to disparage him in any way shape
or form but to [ __ ] business and
they're hitting dates they got a product
to sell if it wasn't [ __ ] you know
you know [ __ ] Justice League it would
be Pepsi or coke like they don't look at
this [ __ ] as we look at it is lie and
I'm not trying to create a divide that
in them in us but look around you like
these people [ __ ] live and die by
these [ __ ] flicks it's our religion
for a lot of cats in this business
that's just what they're doing for this
quarter and stuff like that so I mean
you know and now and and we got a cop to
the fact that shit's gotten way better
quality controls gotten way better and I
think that has everything to do with the
shrinking movie dollar how people just
don't want to [ __ ] leave anymore and
stuff leave their houses to go to a
movie theater so they know when they
stepped up to the plate they gotta come
up with something that [ __ ] people
are incredibly enamored of something
that's gonna capture their imagination
so the ones that are doing it right we
know they are and the ones that are
doing it wrong I guess the ones we're
talking about right now but it seems
like even those cats might figure it out
how to do it right give yourself time
and have lots of creative input it seems
like that would be the key yeah totally
time and money the story of Hollywood
great [ __ ] question you win tickets
give it up I have a second question or
two so my second question you might lose
the question risk I'll risk it my second
question is his question about the team
you guys picked all male characters so
my question to you is for the last
episode a fat man on Batman guys versus
girls who wins girls always
also taxes doesn't have a gender person
[Applause]
non-gendered villainy
fair enough work yeah you got one I got
one
I mean god that's like that tells a
story right there doesn't it like it's
just a male world for me I'm a guy god
that's so [ __ ] weird
is that yeah
Wonder Woman's the Wonder Woman's a
goddess and you guys didn't even i mean
you picked Jesus over women I'm not only
that but I made a movie where God was a
woman and I still picked Jesus know what
I was thinking man I almost went deaf
from the same man universe but I
couldn't decide if she was a hero or a
villain that was my problem there's like
she's just she's a force of nature I
almost picked my wife but I didn't think
that one count but I was like you want
to talk about powerful I know one person
in this world who [ __ ] literally has
her hand up my ass like I'm a puppet
independent cab until I get in that door
then it's like keV the glove that was a
great question you still win the tickets
give it up her last Joe
[Applause]
pleasure we didn't shake hands but
that's totally cool
I just didn't want to get [ __ ] called
out for not Kevin and Mark how you guys
doing hey man what's your name
Tory amador amadora Amador everyone give
it up for Amador man I've been listening
I honestly think I'm deaf I asked like
the question everyone like what you sign
many of my side now I'm like well not
only my deaf but I'm cold and unfeeling
I'm sorry
it's the skinniness now that I have the
weight you know you ain't got no way
well first of all you know since it's
the last fat man on Batman I've been
listening since day one when you were
doing the one-on-ones and then when Mark
came and gave that spicy flavor to it
and when he started doing it here it's
been just a joy to watch and I agree to
do this space this version of the show
is my favorite and you know continuing
on with the new name I can't wait for
many more episodes same old [ __ ]
different name yeah - quick shout outs
to my 500 first guys the six six one
order and my reading rein bros I know
they all watch the show so reading rain
bros yeah we are we meet at a comic book
store twice twice a month at the perky
nerd in Burbank and we pick a couple of
graphic novels and just you know we read
and talk about it and shits and giggles
and all that's that is adorable yeah
yeah oh my god why don't we have
something like that reading any bro
we've we've read some of your guys's
stuff and doesn't know about the reading
rain bros who levar burton does he have
thoughts on the reader I have actually
met levar actually at a karaoke spot and
we talked about it and it was kind of
funny what did he saying he loved it
no what did he sing I want to know if
you levar Burton's go to [ __ ] Jan
I hear he likes to cover the roots a lot
a little bit of ABBA I don't know you
know it it was a good time it was a good
time but anyways so talking about
vacation since both of you especially
mark I saw your Instagram going to San
Francisco my question to you guys are is
you stranded in a desert island what
c-list superhero with no flight
transportation or speed he can't get us
out of there or she no she yes anything
but they're wet because if I would just
say any hero of course Batman would be
the first one to come up but c-list
characters just deep dive any comic book
genre on a desert island
yeah both of you I wanna holland
superhero a queen holly queen he's the
king of the desert island man you
[ __ ] became green arrow and [ __ ] i
wouldn't have to do anything i might go
get us a meal damn
alright Oliver Queen is my god Oliver
Queen I am going to go Tom Hanks said
I'm going to go Jesus Wow
you know go female God from Dogma male
well I guess Jesus I get wine and fish
kind of on tap that's true but to be
fair without Jesus you got fish you're
on a desert island
I don't ride a fish Jesus my damn hungry
Jesus is halibut Ching I'm a little
thirsty he taught me all Jesus he's not
a genie
hmm I feel like the fish powers have
been sorely underrated in with Jesus
pantheon I'd be interesting a shared
desert island with Jesus man I'm
surprised like can you [ __ ] talk to
the fish like Aquaman he's like yeah
watch this I'm not a genie you can't
wish on me can you call your dad is that
does that cover it or did you have a
second part did you have like a real
[ __ ] superhero I have a five part
question No excellent job good question
sign that yes and the other one too all
right
JC we got one set of tickets left who we
got what's your name Lou Chinon I'm
shittin how's it going Kevin a special
Shannon Sh ano it [ __ ] it SH Shannon
Shannon Shannon I gotta get my [ __ ]
hearing jay i literally hear no no
talking to those Amara I did hear
Shannon
have you heard every name I was a little
misty on Anand at first but I think we
got there there's no deal
in mine it's Justin and Shannon give it
up for Shannon man Shannon how are you
oh pretty good first of all I think one
of those Funko pops is up there to give
to somebody so you can give it as
there's a pop here not to me cuz I
already had it I know I understand you
guys amounts but the other one that we
wanted your sign is very special to us
and we keep that that one I treasured
that for always first of all me and me
and Jamie we were at the Alex theater
this one night maybe you can guess which
night we were there last Thursday no
different night the night of yes the
night of and unfortunately we had
tickets to the second show oh you guys
got screws
yeah God dang it all right and to rub it
in even more you know we got to here we
were in line and we got to here like the
audience and stuff on your first show it
was like damn you we're knocking it out
of the park on that first you're like
how'd you do that so myself trying you
you killed it you really you really
killed it out there like sorry oh man
but so but the the point is we're real
close to the same age like we're almost
exactly the same age I just turned 49
and you scared the [ __ ] out of me for
weeks because every time I had a pain
anywhere after Sanford and Son and [ __ ]
so I went to the doctor cuz of you and
got checked out he's like no you're fine
get out get the [ __ ] out of here you're
fine no you check me really good like I
wish I had stats like you you know I'm
like okay great whew so then I feel fine
that's good that's but you know but
thanks anyway you made me feel scared
and then not scared so glad it was like
a fun there have been a few folks on
social media since the heart attack who
sent pictures of themselves in the
hospital like the picture that I took
and [ __ ] go on I listen to you and then
my heart hurt and I went in and triple
bypass and [ __ ] and then they've also
heard an equal amount of stories of
people going like your [ __ ] heart up
so it scared me and I felt bad and I
went to the hospital and they told me I
was crazy right you're fine you like you
like ate something or some [ __ ] okay so
my question is definitely for both of
you guys you know because I've been
working on you know creative projects my
whole life different ones and and sort
of excluding ones that you are
commissioned to do excluding ones that
you are doing with other people and you
have deadlines and money and things that
motivate you right
I'm sure there's like personal projects
that you've worked on and you've
finished to completion if you will and
I've always had a real hard time because
you I get real excited about a project
I'm real I just have that creative
energy and it's spark and I'm
I'm working on and working on and then
either like I'll have another idea and
start working on that and like forget
about that or just it just it just goes
downhill like the spark kind of goes
away that initial you know feeling
you've got your girlfriend you're
looking at the other girl like that meme
you know and so how do you maintain that
so that you can complete a project you
know how do you stay motivated in in
what oh and I know that you okay and I
know you guys could do it it's just why
I'm here asking you the questions so
what can you speak to that like can you
help me out what what what can I do what
do you do I spin a lot of plates for
that very reason because not everything
happens and when I began my career I was
only doing one thing trying to make
movies and I made a movie and somebody
bought it and then people like what you
want to do I was like making another
movie and I pitched it and they liked it
we made it so that's what I would do
that's how I'd lived the first three
years of my career was making one movie
at a time per year or every other year
or something like that and then that
gets frustrating because you put all
your eggs in one basket and so you're
waiting for news like I remember like
sitting by the phone for three months
waiting for like chasing a me phone call
just for them to be like yes or no
anything and [ __ ] like that and every
day you wake up and you just [ __ ]
willing the phone to ring and stuff like
that so I don't ever want to live like
that again at an early point in my
career I was like look just have other
[ __ ] to do like be doing other [ __ ]
so I started spinning a bunch of plates
so the only reason you see like me doing
as many things as I do is because I'm
terrified of doing one thing and having
that one
thing not come to fruition so you know
I've had there's plenty of stuff that
I've talked about wanting to do over the
last few years case in point hit
somebody a hockey movie that became two
hockey movies that became a hockey
miniseries and is still a hockey fantasy
in my head seven scripts written but no
[ __ ] no concrete home floor
you've got unfinished things - oh
absolutely I have more unfinished things
than finished things you only see the
everybody but be fair I'm always out
there talking about the unfinished
things were the things that I want to
make that's the only way I can make [ __ ]
happen throw your hat over the wall and
start talking about and saying I'm gonna
do this and you just create the truth
like you know it's you're willing it
into existence
sometimes that absolutely [ __ ] works
case in point my entire [ __ ]
cinematic career even up to and
including [ __ ] tusks and yoga if you
don't get to make those movies without
willing them - I saw it all the way to
the end thank you so what the but the
notion of like making all of it happened
like he just can't so hit somebody has
taken me a while to find a home for
moose jaw's has taken me a while to find
a home for I don't let him go I'm not
like they're done I just let them
quietly simmer on the back burner while
something else moves forward and work on
that for a little bit but I keep them
all alive I'm never like this is done
and it will sit in a drawer and nobody
will ever [ __ ] say it and stuff
there's always hope you sound like the
voice in my head what this is over no
one's ever gonna see you know yeah I
refuse to believe that I honestly
believe that like and I've said it
before you can have everything you want
in this life all your dreams will come
true they just will never come true on
the schedule you want them to and never
in the way that you think they will so
if you nurture it enough and [ __ ] like
that
you get what you want I'm starting to
get things now that I stopped wanting
ten years ago but I did want them at one
point so even now I'm like oh [ __ ] you
wanted this at one point so keep [ __ ]
alive like and and that way you can
close those circles but no if that helps
you buy a binding
want a stretch of the imagination there
are a lot of things that I haven't
[ __ ] been able to do yet that I've
tried over and over again but you just
hold that hope and and ever fall word
hoping that like before I leave this
world I'll get to do all the things that
I've set in motion if I don't don't
[ __ ] matter I've already done enough
but I'm I just that's what keeps me
going is like no hits somebody will
happen and it ain't happening yet but
it's gonna happen if I have to take
alternative routes to get there like you
know if I can I put up a couple episodes
of the script on SModcast and stuff and
that God has traction in this other
place and now hit somebody is going to
come to life in a different way than I
intended but would probably be on the
road to where I eventually want to go
it's just gonna take time and so I've
learned to give it time like if the
universe you can't [ __ ] force the
universe to do everything you want I'm
lucky to be able to [ __ ] force it to
do tusk that's [ __ ] amazing and [ __ ]
like this but some [ __ ] takes a little
bit longer so I don't get shitty about
it I just busy myself with with other
things perfect example is my kid
recently my kids an actress she didn't
go to college this year it's all about
[ __ ] auditioning and stuff like that
she's like I'm gonna be an actress
working actress and look great fantastic
just know that it doesn't work according
to your schedule and stuff like that so
you know she's had a tough year of it in
terms of like what she hoped for him
what she wound up doing have been two
different things so a couple months ago
she her and her friend got busy making
this EP they made this [ __ ] EP they
got a band called the 10th it's really
nice like bubblegum punk stuff man her
friend Taylor my F when I heard it she
was like you won't listen to my EP and I
was like okay you know hugging hoping
that it wasn't terrible and it was
actually [ __ ] legit good where I was
like well done and [ __ ] like then she's
like you lookin at me like you're
surprised you know so she was busy with
this [ __ ] thing and then out of
nowhere she just got the role of a
[ __ ] lifetime and she was like oh my
god and it changes her life like it's
it's [ __ ] magic this wasn't what she
was originally it was something she was
originally
but it was out of her reach and went
away she wasn't worked on something else
didn't think about it and then it came
back to life so I was like the lesson
you got a [ __ ] take from this is
never one thing always as many things as
you can do that way you won't stare at a
[ __ ] phone waiting for it to happen
you won't [ __ ] sit there and be like
why didn't I get this you'll be doing
something else you'll be living your
life and making your art while waiting
while somebody else is making decisions
about that but I ain't gonna make
[ __ ] make hold you up
you could still [ __ ] be creating
stuff so that's what I do
I just [ __ ] start a lot of projects
and I keep them all [ __ ] going some
move forward at a quicker pace than
others and stuff but I keep them all
[ __ ] idling because you never know
which one's gonna be got a pivot from
thing to thing and whatnot
unless you want you like downtime you're
like being bored and I hate downtime
I don't like vacations [ __ ] Labor Day
weekend like sucked for me I'm like
nobody's working so like for me I like
to keep everything kind of moving even
over the weekend I was like I'm gonna go
back into a [ __ ] script and just [ __ ]
with it and [ __ ] like that you a buddy
my guy named John Rogers who was the
showrunner of leverage and the
librarians and oh he used to have a
poster above his computer or just a
couple of words just this big [ __ ]
text that said done is the engine of
more explain that what Dan's done does
meaning do Andy yes done is the engine
of more done is the engine a little more
more mo re yes explain that from yeah
that like completion breeds Genesis
breeds completion breeds Genesis you
will do more if you finish more and like
Hollywood is littered with the first act
and a half of screen players it's true
of people who just kind of started gonna
lose their way and I did write right out
or whatever and you know it's it's hard
it's unmistakeably not crushingly hard
to do this work but you have to fall in
love with the endings of your stories
because otherwise you won't be
incentivized to get there
you have to love the downhill entering
the finale where the wind of stories in
your hair and the characters are telling
you what they should be doing and you
were just living you're inhaling it as
it goes you have to be finishing stuff
now whether or not that should get sold
whether or not you've managed to
interest anybody in it nobody will call
you for an idea that you haven't written
nobody will ever ask you for the script
that you haven't finished yet they will
want to know what can you show me and my
hard drive is littered with like just
hundreds of ideas and dozens of
treatments and a good eight pilots that
I wrote a good couple of movies that I
wrote because I fell in love with them
at some point I'll go back to the other
hundred ideas and find the one or two
that I still like in our habits there's
something there but it's probably never
gonna happen because I didn't already
write it I wasn't so [ __ ] enthused by
it that I didn't sit down today and
start writing it and like those are idle
fantasies and it's great to have them
but you gotta finish because if you
don't finish
you can't show and if you can't show you
didn't get paid if you don't get paid
you don't do more done is the engine of
more find ways to finish final ways to
complete I mean these ideas he's talking
about is like he's got a script for hit
somebody's got a script for these things
he's got he did as much work as he can
until the moment where somebody else has
to get involved I think you're not
grinding each one until it's finished
though like you will stop one and go to
other but you still finish some finish
hundreds of treatment it's great to have
a couple of things in hey I've got five
pilots if somebody wants one I go you
know like yeah here's another one here's
another one but unless you finish unless
you get to the end of it unless you find
a way to fall in love with finishing
stuff you just won't because the
beginnings are easy the beginnings it's
like a [ __ ] road race like
everybody's got a good idea that's right
that's what I'm saying it's like getting
past that you got to get past you got to
push yourself a lot of following love
even and then finish
and even to exorcise the demon of not
finishing doesn't matter if it's good or
not just complete finish because
otherwise if you leave one behind
unfinished the next one's easier to
leave behind unfinished the next one and
then it becomes a trail of series of you
know twenty pages of something that
doesn't coalesce into anything when all
put together and stuff right so finish
because you start and you're in love
with the idea you know even if it starts
becoming work and stuff like that work
through like nothing worthwhile is easy
and you know everybody's got a great
idea for a cool story
but not everyone [ __ ] writes is right
not at your next movie because it
requires you to sometimes go further
than just having a good idea go to a
place you're uncomfortable go to a place
and not like you know uncomfortable like
I'm sucking my own dick in front of the
computer I'm not talking about that
although if you can do it put a camera
on that's not comfortable at all three
acts right act one or two or three act
one is must act one is the I saw that
woman she's [ __ ] hot as hell I cannot
wait to get in that or man or man
it is it is it super is yeah it is the
heat of romance it is the heat of
passion yeah the second act is [ __ ]
misery it's the oh Jesus you were not
what I thought you were going to be you
turned out to love [ __ ] that I don't
actually like already already the third
act is resolution the third act is we've
resolved to find the things in each
other that we're good at to find the
things in each other we can respond with
and to together make it to the end of
this [ __ ] story and everybody falls
in love everybody's got that first act
because it's hot and it's awesome and
it's it's nothing but immediate [ __ ]
like pleasure centers of your brain
firing off everybody gives up in the
second act because it's [ __ ] hard but
you've got to find a way to get to good
it gets good because once you're all on
the same page literally and figuratively
once you all understand the nature of
your relationship then it's [ __ ]
awesome that's what like marriages and
you're gonna be married to this thing
for the rest of your life because you
wrote it you finished it and if you do
it well and if you
guys find a way to work through your
difficulties of the second act and make
that [ __ ] work out it is nothing but joy
once you get to the end of that thing
and you finished it and you're done and
even the worst script is a script and
you can rewrite it you can make it
better you can go to counseling you can
figure out ways invite some friends over
hey guys you know we really need a third
person that you could submit that [ __ ]
to the reading rainbows and they'll
[ __ ] tell you know I'll try I'll tell
you if you're on the right track but
unless you finish it and none of that
stuff gets to happen it can't do
anything for you right until it's done
so incentivize that being done as
opposed to they here's a new shiny idea
over in the corner that I'm totally in
lust with I'm gonna write that instead
no stay get to you when I'm done get
done also in finishing you own the words
the words don't own you
it's a dangerous precedent to set when
people are like I'm blocked that's
letting the words own you never be
blocked just write something write
anything start [ __ ] right and like
Nicholson and The Shining if that's what
it takes do 400 pages of like all work
and no play makes Jack a dull boy you'll
break through but you have to keep
[ __ ] writing if the words on you
you're [ __ ] man you master these words
they come out of you you're the one that
puts them together and such a magical
way that they have an impact on people
it's a [ __ ] spell so just make sure
you finish the incantation halfway you
know [ __ ] that's how Voldemort get
something you're not gonna summon
anything speaking of things that were
bad but we finished we started a podcast
me and Jamie so what is the name of the
prop guy is called married with TV
married with tv.com married with TV
Twitter I see married
yeah married with if he's married with
TV comm a podcast 20 years in the making
only now we actually recorders you and B
are just bullshitting about TV and [ __ ]
like and we've been doing it our whole
lives and so we'd like we should record
this [ __ ] we are 10 years and so finally
you know like by now you're really good
at podcasting like you really have this
like like flow going this is where the
the sausage is made and we're just
learning how to get it so you can hear
me doing that on the earliest episodes
of SModcast man I think episode 2 of
SModcast me emoji are sitting around and
I'm like do you know how many [ __ ]
followers I got on MySpace [ __ ] how
many I was like there's over a million
people man if we get every one of them
to give us a dollar we'd have a million
bucks to go make a movie with isn't that
[ __ ] up and then a year later somebody
was like here's Kickstarter yeah I don't
feel we created the idea but we were
kind of on that path it's rather like
hey man there's something to be done
with the audience here and stuff so you
can hear the earliest fumblings of two
people trying to figure out what a
podcast is and those early episodes of
podcast it's not pretty
you know we're figuring it out suddenly
we hit the ground [ __ ] running and
stuff by the time I hooked up with this
guy I'd had a few hundred hours talking
with other people and yes you were like
[ __ ] Tom Hanks and that thing you do
like come and join this SModcast movie
I'm Steve Zahn yeah the o-neders it's
great
that's [ __ ] that's a great Paul Bob
be honest with you in my heart you'll
always be live Tyler
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this evening
we ain't got a show without the smart
man to my left the guy who figured out
that [ __ ] luggage analogy in that
[ __ ] movie
and I can't wait to go home and [ __ ]
tell my kid do you know why he worked in
luggage factory jiffy look not again you
know and start crying and [ __ ] give it
up for mark barnard lady and that is fat
man I'm Batman for this week I'm killing
forever and forever I'm Kevin Smith I am
Marc menorah tune in next time same fad
time same fat channel spot gasps calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
you